summer is over and now the time has come
to dance
hey everyone my name is Matt Bella Sian
this is whine about it a weekly video
series where I get drunk at my desk and
complain about stuff on this week's
episode the most annoying people to text
with is the average person since like 60
messages a day and they're all garbage
that's what the study said and you
should feel bad about the textual filth
that you're polluting this world with
all right let's strength yeah I got a
message all right first of all anybody
you text the phrase did you get my
message
they're always like did you get my
message that I sent these on the same
medium that I'm using to send this
message so if you didn't get the first
one you're probably not gonna get this
one either but I don't care because I'm
an annoying piece of [ __ ] I'm gonna send
you a second one anyway that's what they
say that's what they said there's only
two reasons that someone doesn't reply
to your message one they were [ __ ]
busy and two they didn't want to find
reply to your message asking someone did
you get my message as like I said
someone why do you hate me
I don't think you're ready for the
answer okay there's people who respond
to messages with the old
passive-aggressive Kay there's
respondent to my whole message with one
letter in a period after it you trying
to start a fight with me is that what
you want you want to dance with the
Beast
nobody says Kay unless they think you
done set them up don't you dare text me
Kay unless you're ready to throw down
also pre will respond to messages with
just a whole string of indecipherable
emojis you're not a [ __ ] caveman what
I look like so I'm gonna hieroglyphics
reading scientists trying to read up all
the pictures on your cave wall I asked
you if you wanted to go out tonight and
all you sent me was six corns on the cob
an octopus and
a pair what's that what's that is that
yes what's that mean was a text message
not a menu at Denny's
use your words not just little pictures
of a foods also anybody who sends a
message that's longer than like two
sentences I just wanted a yes or a No
not Moby Dick also people who turn every
message until like 16 different messages
I was like hey said Matt said I think I
found send some nachos said oh wait sent
a bird pooped on them said I think I got
most of it off said do you still want to
split them said you could have just sum
that up in one message so my phone
doesn't stop blowing up like the Alamo I
only need one
[ __ ] message from you at a time okay
okay the others people who take like
seven hours to respond to a message that
needs a response right now if I say what
flavor of ice cream do you want I'm not
[ __ ] around okay this is an emergency
that requires your immediate attention
so while you take your hand out of your
pants and let me know what flavor of ice
cream that you want lives are on the
line here and you can't respond to my
text message
but also people who expect me to respond
right away when I'm busy they're always
like mad
you left your oven on again Matt there's
smoke billowing out of your apartment
Matt why won't you answer your phone
listen sometimes I got better things to
do they'll reply to your text message
like getting home to the delicious bagel
bites that I left bacon in my oven
before I left the house this morning
but I guess I guess you wouldn't know
about that would you you know about the
finer things of life you're too busy
texted me every five damn seconds now
there's that one sack who asked the
question can I ask you a question I
don't know Michelle this isn't a big
game texting is a serious business you
can't just ask a question and then ask
another
question it's all there black and white
clear is crystal you so fizzy lifting
drinks you bumped into the ceiling which
now is to be washed and sterilized so
you get nothing
you lose good day sir it's from them of
movie with wall Wally Wonka
and finally worst of all there's the
people who call you instead of sending a
text message it was like Matt can you
talk is now a good time to talk no it's
not a good time to talk it's never a
good time to talk does anything you
could say to me you say in a text
message better you called me on the
phone that's for goddamn sure that's for
damn sure
alright everybody they were watching
this week as always you can find our
videos every week at wide about it's a
tumblr comm and my page which is
facebook.com/buzzfeedmatt that's it
that's everything that's all I got
people always come up to roust real they
say or oh you're Matt you're the wide
guy from BuzzFeed and I say nope I'm 17
time Academy Award winner meryl streep I
understand the confusion
have a nice day have a good day I'm
gonna have them on the back and then I
say oh my god she is wonderful I can't
believe I just met Meryl Streep